Democrats and Republicans liberals and
conservatives all agree we've got to cut
large chunks of government spending over
the next decade or else we've got to
start learning how to speak Greek the
Congressional Budget Office projects
that if we keep spending the way we have
been federal debt held by the public
will grow from around sixty percent of
GDP to a whopping eighty two percent
conservative Republicans are happy to
talk about cutting spending on the poor
on education and even on cowboy poetry
readings but they insist that spending
on defense not only not be trimmed but
that it be increased here are three
reasons conservatives and all other
red-blooded Americans should cut defense
spending now
didn't we just win or at least end the
war in Iraq and aren't we winding down
in Afghanistan after world war two
Vietnam and the end of the Cold War
military spending got cut as it should
more to the point spending on the
military and homeland security has grown
by 90 percent in inflation-adjusted
dollars since 2000 if al Qaeda and most
international terrorist groups have been
largely vanquished we should not just be
bringing the troops home but the dollars
- unless that is conservatives want to
seriously argue that nearly doubling
outlays for the past decade haven't
yielded results that would allow us to
dial down defense spending the United
States already accounts for about 45
percent of the planet's military outlays
more than the next 14 countries combined
it's a conservative truism that
government programs even ones that are
sanctioned by the Constitution tend to
be bloated inefficient and incompetent
surely that logic applies to the
Pentagon in the Department of Homeland
Security in fact after spending fifty
six billion dollars in security measures
flying is no safer now than it was
before the 9/11 attacks
it was a republican president the war
here at Dwight Eisenhower who sounded
the alarm about the military industrial
complexes insidious ability to grow and
grow like a cancer on the American body
politic Americans are rightly tired not
just the dubious inconclusive wars that
have led to the death of thousands of
Americans and hundreds of thousands of
others they're all so tired of
out-of-control spending by a Washington
elite that is totally out of touch with
everyday Americans if conservatives want
to push forward on reducing spending on
Medicaid and other domestic programs
they should show that they take their
own limited government philosophy
seriously by pushing for defense cuts
between now and the 2012 elections for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie